HOST: All right, gentlemen.
There will be a strength
test, a sharpness test,
and up first, the kill test.
Doug?
[music playing]
DOUG: To see how
lethal your weapon is,
I will take your spear
and deliver lethal blows
on this pig carcass.
Matt, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Ready as I'll ever be.
DOUG: Let's do this.
MATT: What I'm
most worried about
is lateral force on
this spear, because it's
a very thin, sleek spear.
[music playing]
[spear clattering]
Well, that sucks.
[music playing]
Matt, I'm not gonna
sugarcoat it-- this is bad.
Your weapon has suffered
a catastrophic failure,
and cannot continue
with testing.
However, John, we
can't just declare
you the [inaudible] champion.
Your blade has to hold
up for at least a stab
and a slash on this carcass.
Doug?
[music playing]
JOHN: I don't know what to say,
I don't know what to think.
I've never been more, you
know, nervous in my life.
I'm hoping and praying that it
doesn't break in the same spot.
[music playing]
Bladesmiths, as
they're designed,
these tests push your
weapons to the limit.
John, your blade survived
the two cuts on our carcass.
Matt, that means,
unfortunately, your blade
did not make the cut,
and I have to ask
you to please leave the forge.
Congrats, man.
I'm happy for you.
[music playing]
I'm disappointed.
Given what I know now, I would
have gone back and really
tried chopping something
very hard with the spear,
and hopefully broken
the handle myself.
I'm really happy for John.
Maybe I'm not happy to lose to
John, but I'm glad John won.